continúa las evacuaciones en gerson con
pocas pertenencias y mucho temor miles
de residentes de esta ciudad del sur de
Ucrania huyen desesperados el ejército
ruso los instó a abandonar sus hogares
Durante los próximos días se espera que
el ejército de kiev realice una
contraofensiva para recuperar el terreno
anexionado por Moscú alrededor de 10
autobuses transportaban refugiados hoy
ayudamos tanto como pudimos movimos
cosas algunos fueron transportados en
minibús a la ciudad otros fueron
escoltados a estaciones suburbanas
Rusia planeaba actuar entre 50.000 y
60.000 personas de la urbe la cual tenía
unos
284.000 habitantes antes de ser invadida
por los rusos al principio de la guerra
Esta es una zona de alto interés para
ambos lados del conflicto se trata de un
objetivo principal debido a sus
industrias clave y Su importante Puerto
fluvial Durante los últimos días gerson
ha sido testigo de fuertes
enfrentamientos alrededor de 2000 rusos
han llegado a la ciudad mientras las
fuerzas ucranianas continúan aumentando
la presión en la región
nos ofrecieron salir debido a la difícil
situación recibimos mensajes de texto
no no tomamos una decisión de inmediato
pero luego nuestros amigos y familiares
nos invitaron y ahora nos vamos a Moscú
esperamos tiempos mejores y queremos
volver a nuestro gerson natal ya Google
entre tanto Ucrania pidió el viernes una
misión de observación internacional en
la presa de jacobca quien facusa Moscú
de preparar ataques que inundarían una
vasta zona del Sur ucraniano